this is from patrick dean via twitter
with all the incredible
online content out there all the great
videos and articles about everything
from personal development and outdoor
athletes to literary and social issues
how can we best ration our time thanks
patrick
it's a good question i think i think the
important thing to bear in mind
is your ratio of consumption to creation
there's this illusion of productivity
that occurs
um when we're consuming uplifting
content we think we're actually doing
something because
what we're receiving is uplifting and
it's educational
and it's informative and it makes us
feel like
we're capable of achieving our goals
but the illusion of course is that it
convinces you that you've actually done
something when you haven't
so i think it's really important first
of all that's it's good
i think it's really important to be
mindful of your information diet the
kind of content that you're choosing to
consume
on a daily basis that's a great question
in that regard yeah
and and to the extent that we're in this
you know
stay-at-home moment for a lot of us
we're spending much more time
in front of our screens and it's easy to
just
click and click and click and and
mindlessly just
hit the next youtube you know video
without thinking through
is this the best allocation of my time
oh it hits it for you
oh it does yeah oh yeah it'll just play
yeah unless you do anything
interrupt the flow exactly just relax in
the barca lounger
so yeah so you gotta you gotta first be
mindful about that diet
your information diet your entertainment
diet and make sure
that you're calibrating it so that it's
in your best interest
then you have to check the valence of
consumption versus creation
there's a lot of talk about screen time
but
i think screen time is too broad a term
because you can be using screen time
to write a book or like matisse edit a
video
or you know write a poem like there's
create music there's there's plenty of
creative productive
positive ways to use screen time where
you're actually
in the creation process rather than the
consumptive process so the first thing
is
doing an inventory of how much of your
screen time is consumptive versus
creative
and trying to calibrate that valence so
that you're using your screen time for
more creative output and then
being objectively honest with yourself
about the extent to which
you're consuming content and perhaps
diluting yourself into
thinking that that's actually um moving
you
towards your goals i guess is the best
way of answering that question
i like that do you digest or do you
produce and
if you're not leveraging the content
that you're consuming
to produce or make changes or create
forward motion in your own life
then it becomes a distraction gary v
says this all the time he's like
i hope that you stop listening to me and
watching me one day because
if you're stuck on just watching those
people who are motivating you but you're
not acting like if you just watch
david goggins videos all day long but
you never put the running shoes on and
go outside or do a single push-up
then you're missing the whole point of
what he's trying to
explain to you yeah right agreed i like
that the ratio of consumption versus
creation
for me i think of screen time and i
don't i don't even think about my
computer it's it's rare that like i'm
on the computer unless i'm writing or
working i think of my phone and when i'm
on my phone
the screen time really is a consumptive
experience it's not so much a creative
experience although i do take notes in
my phone sometimes so it can
it can blur the line what about all
those tick tock dance moves
you got going on bro don't don't tell
them about my tick tock name
do not do not mention my tick tock
handle
um so in terms of consumption are there
like two or three
kind of go-to things that you're always
hitting like is there is there like a
guilty pleasure or is there
something that you're always like is
there a podcast that you kind of
listen to on a regular basis uh beyond
just
kind of just something for you not
really even for work
i mean i would say podcasts are are
the thing that i consume the most on on
my phone uh
and i've been consuming a little bit
less because i'm not in my car as much
but when i'm out training it's
definitely you know that's my go-to
form of edutainment and i mix it up
i mean i have to look at my phone to
tell you what i'm listening to lately
but it tends to be yeah sometimes i'll
use it
i i listen to stuff that has nothing to
do with anything that we talk about here
like if i
you know i'm not listening to the shows
that are similar to my own because that
feels like homework
right and i need to you know broaden my
perspective in other areas so i listen
to like a lot of tech stuff i like
kara swisher and scott galloway on their
pivot podcast i like
i like professor galloway's new prof g
show i've been listening to that i like
reply all which is stories about the
internet oh cool they're fascinating
like long form kind of journalistic
deep dives into weird corners of the
internet i think that uh
those guys pj and uh alex who hosts that
show do an amazing job you know i like
storytelling
yeah i'll listen to some rogan podcasts
but not all of them you know
i i mix it up gladwell yeah gladwell for
sure yeah
who is i'll say it right now nobody does
an ad read
like malcolm gladwell he throws his
whole body into it that's a full body
experience i want to watch there's a
whole
production that goes into how he crafts
these ad reads and the writing
that that it's funny well you get it
it's where he gets to be funny i think
more than anything and right and he is
funny
um but yeah i was listening to revisions
history the last couple of days it's
good new season is out
big fan it is he's another guy i'm
trying to get on the show we've had
emails back and forth and
haven't been able to make scheduling
happen and that's one i really want to
do in person
so i'm willing to wait a little bit
longer
[Music]
you